[Música]
Hola y bienvenidos yo soy Esther Herrera
caro desde los estudios de París de
Franz 24 un placer saludarles a todos
hoy hablamos con el alto representante
de la Unión Europea para la política
exterior josep borrell que se encuentra
ahora mismo en Nueva York con motivo de
la asamblea general de la ONU han sido
unos días Muy intensos muy marcados por
la guerra en Ucrania señor alto
representante Muchas gracias por estar
en fans de 24
gracias a ustedes gracias por la
oportunidad a usted tras los recientes
anuncios de Vladimir Putin como la
movilización parcial de tropas usted
se reunistros de exteriores de la Unión
Europea en Nueva York y acordaron en
preparar un nuevo paquete de sanciones
se va a incluir un tope al precio del
petróleo
el límite al precio del petróleo ya es
un acuerdo tomado en el marco del g7 que
tendrá que ser adoptado por la Unión
Europea Pero antes de fin de año ya
hemos decidido todos los países salvo
uno que vamos a dejar de comprar
petróleo ruso por lo tanto para nosotros
el límite del petróleo con límite o sin
límite no vamos a comprar más petróleo
ruso a partir de diciembre pero es un
límite que quisiéramos que el resto del
mundo siguiera también el g7 está en
Estados Unidos Japón el Reino Unido si
quisiéramos limitar de hecho estamos
limitando ya mucho los ingresos que
Putin obtiene por la venta de sus
hidrocarburos justamente comenta que
querría que otros países se unieran cree
que hay esta posibilidad porque a menudo
se comenta que estas sanciones
básicamente las Escoge occidente las
decide occidente Pero qué pasa con el
resto del mundo
no todo el mundo ha decidido aplicar
sanciones a Rusia es cierto o
sensaciones adoptadas libremente por los
países que creen que tienen que hacerlo
los Estados Unidos Canadá el Reino Unido
los países europeos otros países han
adoptado exactamente a las mismas que
nosotros y otros han decidido no hacerlo
hay una parte de la guerra de la guerra
que se libra con armas con armas que
matan hay otra guerra que es otra
batalla que es la batalla de las ideas
de las razones de la narrativa que se
dice ahora de la historia que cada uno
cuenta y ayer en el Consejo de Seguridad
ciertamente la historia que contaba la
profe era radicalmente distinta de la
que contábamos tanto secretarios del
Estado americano como como yo mismo hay
un discurso y ese discurso es algunos
países lo compran y otros lo rechazan
hay que participar en esta batalla de
ideas hay que explicar Cuáles son las
causas de los problemas que muchos
países están sufriendo gravemente
algunos de ellos muy gravemente en
términos de precios
de energías por supuesto de alimentación
por supuesto pero también de altos tipos
de interés una inflación que genera una
respuesta de los bancos centrales que va
a crear una crisis financiera y
económica hay que explicar Por qué
ocurre eso y hay que ayudar a los países
más vulnerables a que hagan frente a
esta crisis
estamos viendo las imágenes de muchos
hombres en edad de combatir abandonando
Rusia los países de la Unión Europea
deberían acoger a estas personas darles
asilo
las obligaciones de dar asilos siguen
siendo las mismas los estados miembros
pueden rechazar a turistas de hecho se
acordó limitar el número de visados
porque se creía que había demasiadas
rusos que iban a tomar el sol o copas en
los países europeos en un momento en que
había una guerra en la que su país
participaba de una forma dramática otra
cosa es la persona que huye no va a
tomar el sol simplemente se escapa y
pide asilo las demandas de asilo tienen
que ser atendidas lo eran antes durante
y después de la guerra y cada estado
miembro tendrá que hacer frente a sus
obligaciones humanitarias
analizando las peticiones de los
ciudadanos que piden asilo porque huyen
huyen de algo huyen por ejemplo del
peligro que esa conscripción que más se
parece a una rassia
a cambio de sus vidas unas imágenes que
vemos de los ciudadanos rusos llamados a
abandonando sus casas despidiendo de sus
familias subiendo en autobuses para ir a
la guerra no son precisamente imágenes
de gente entusiasta usted
estaba hablando las ideas al pidió
recientemente en el parlamento europeo
de los ciudadanos europeos que no
desfallezcan que sigan apoyando a
Ucrania teme que a medida que se acerque
el invierno la gente tenga más problemas
para pagar las facturas y que este apoyo
se vaya reduciendo
hay que hay que ayudar a las familias
más vulnerables con menos recursos hacer
frente a una situación de carestía de
los precios de la energía y también de
la Alimentación en lo están haciendo los
estados miembros a través de muchas
medidas de reducción de precios o de
ayudas sociales y habrá que hacerlo a
los que tengan necesidad de ayuda habrá
que dársela pero hay muchos que podemos
gracias a unos niveles de ingresos
suficientes hacer frente a una situación
de restricción la restricción que pasa
también por una disminución del consumo
energético hay familias que ya no pueden
disminuirlo más porque
no consumen nada que no consume nada no
puede consumir menos pero otros que
consumen bastante si pueden consumir
menos si pueden reducir un grado la
temperatura de sus casas y pueden
ahorrar energía
y entre todos tenemos que hacer frente a
una situación que para pues puede ser
difícil pero que es mucho más difícil
para los ucranianos
al hilo también de esta batalla de ideas
durante la semana de reuniones en Nueva
York la agenda estaba muy marcada por
esta guerra en Ucrania pero también una
sensación de que la propaganda rusa cala
más en ciertos países en ciertas
regiones me gustaría concentrarme por
ejemplo en América Latina en que la
cuestión de los fertilizantes preocupa
mucho ha tenido usted esta sensación
muchas ocasiones antes y durante la
húngara he tenido muchas ocasiones para
hablar con mis colegas de todo el mundo
y soy muy consciente de que la narrativa
rusa en algunos casos cae en terreno
fértil que también hay una actitud
antiimperialista en algunos países de
América Latina que no les hace sentir
muy muy cerca de las posiciones de
Estados Unidos y En África hay
posiciones anticoloniales del viejo
reflejo anticolonial
la proximidad a un país Rusia que en la
heredera de la unión soviética que les
ayudó unas guerras de la independencia
hay actitudes de históricas
causadas por las circunstancias que cada
país ha vivido y luego también están los
problemas inmediatos la gente
decisivale muy bien ya sabemos que suele
invadir al vecino es muy malo y lo
rechazamos y lo condenamos Pero tenemos
un problema
tenemos un problema grave de
alimentación de precios de la energía de
falta de fertilizantes
tenemos un problema y tenemos que hacer
frente ese problema y hay que ayudarles
ya que hagan frente ahí hay que
ayudarles hay que comprometerse más con
el resto del mundo
señor alto representante tiene la
sensación con esta retórica ante
imperialista que antes ha comentado de
que la Unión Europea está perdiendo
influencia en América Latina respecto a
China y a Rusia
no seguimos siendo el principal inversor
en América Latina y seguimos trabajando
con los países latinoamericanos con los
que nos suceden lazos históricos
culturales lingüísticos de una enorme
potencia pero tenemos que comprometernos
más con todos los países del Mundo con
América Latina también Muchas gracias
por su por su entrevista Muchísimas
gracias alto representante por estar con
nosotros Le agradezco mucho su tiempo a
ustedes les esperamos en la próxima
programación de France 24 en español
sigan con nosotros
[Música]